my girl is Indian - I didn't sell out
like Quinn all I love her I do it for
real I will say this though there's this
odd stereotype I've noticed that Indian
men are all monsters and Indian women
are these sweet submissive docile angels
floating about the earth I'll tell you
this right now
if Indian women are angels I'll go to
hell I don't need it like that there's
now crazy Indian women are is literally
built into our religion who here is
Hindu yep
what do we die what do we do we we
create now we cremate the body and then
we spread the ashes in a Ganga river
then we get reincarnated that's how
crazy Indian women are when white men
die their wife finds a beautiful plot of
land and places them in the earth in a
mahogany casket with a headstone and
then visits the headstone with flowers
puts his favorite football jersey on the
tombstone and then talks to him oh my
god the kids miss you so much
the dog hasn't eaten since you passed
it's just so hard without you
Indian member like look when I die get
me as far away from this [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
just sent me on fire leaving nothing and
then I want you to take those ashes and
drop them in a current and the friend
was probably like what do you mean like
the pond behind house no no that's where
the [ __ ] does laundry you find the
biggest most powerful river in India and
then you dump me in so by the time she's
ready to nag I'll be in Sri Lanka why do
they have funerals we have escape routes
[Music]